Ladies and gentlemen, we proudly present...
...the BlackBerry Z10 and the BlackBerry Q10.
Two brand new devices, and perhaps a fresh start for a company...
...that has seen its global market share plummet from 20 percent three years ago...
...to just over three percent today.
For BlackBerry CEO Thorsten Heins, it's another chance to remake a faded brand.
We have definitely been on a journey of transformation,...
...a journey to not only transform our business and our brand,...
...but one which I truly believe will transform mobile communications into true mobile computing.
The company promises the same high level of network security the BlackBerry is known for,...
...along with a fast new browser, a more intuitive operating system,...
...and a revamped library featuring more than 70,000 apps.
The Z10 looks much like the touchscreen phones popularized by its rivals,...
...but the Q10 maintains the "qwerty" keyboard that has become BlackBerry's trademark.
Besides the technical and cosmetic updates,...
...Heins says the company will no longer be called RIM, or Research in Motion.
Our customers use a BlackBerry, our employees work for BlackBerry,...
...and our shareholders are owners of BlackBerry.
From today on, we are BlackBerry everywhere in the world.
Shareholders will be watching if customers adopt the new devices.
The company's stock has dropped as much as 90 percent in the last four years...
...as it lost ground to competitors,...
...but company shares have doubled in the last four months...
...as anticipation grew for the new models.
Analysts say the new devices could make or break a company...
...that many credit for starting the technological revolution in smartphones.
Mil Arcega, VOA News, Washington.